[Music]
if you're watching this video there's a
pretty good chance that you shouldn't be
watching it and should be doing
something more productive instead but if
you've already done your work good for
you either way here are four useful
strategies you can use right now or in
the future when you really need it that
will help you stop browsing memes and
get to work number one install
cold-turkey writer on your PC or Mac if
you have a paper to write and you can't
stay focused long enough to start it
cold turkey writer is the right app for
you you set the amount of words you want
to write hit enter and it will literally
not let you leave the app until you hit
your word count goal
you can't Altaf or you can't control
to escape you just have to do the
work
number two install the forest app on
Chrome I talked about forest in an
earlier video but I didn't really dive
into what it actually does basically you
plant a seed in the next 30 minutes this
seed will gradually grow into a tree
however if you can't resist the
temptation and start to browse the
websites on your blacklist your tree
will wither away and die it's a pretty
simple app it works pretty well and you
should definitely give it a try number 3
develop a sacred productivity playlist
so I mentioned the sacred space in an
earlier video which is a particular
geographical location a coffee shop
library that you treat with the utmost
respect and reverence for productivity
but I'm also a big fan of music and
think that everyone should have a
Productivity playlist a playlist full of
good study music that you only listen to
when you're being productive and you're
only productive when you're listening to
it so when you press start on that
productivity playlist you have no choice
but to close down all the memes close
down YouTube Facebook and all that and
start writing the best damn paper you've
ever written and finally number four and
this is going to sound pretty archaic
but disable your internet sometimes the
poll to waste time on the Internet is so
strong you literally have to tear away
yourself from the distraction if your
paper or whatever you're working on can
at least be started offline then do it
offline honestly with the internet
disabled you'll probably get so bored
that you'll actually want to start
hacking away at the paper or whatever
else you have to be doing so that's it
maybe some of these tips seem a little
bit extreme to you but sometimes that's
the way it's got to be often the best
way to regain focus is to completely
eliminate the distraction from the
equation so if you've got work to do
like the video subscribe to the channel
get off YouTube and get to work